Thank You Nikhil
so what I want to do in this talk is I
want to get you familiar with a maybe
also not so well-known model for
scheduling under uncertainty and that is
scheduling with stochastic processing
times so the talk is going to be a very
mild introductory or mini introductory
lecture into this model of stochastic
machine scheduling and I try to do that
along with some of the recent results
that we obtained for that model and that
is results that I got together with
Martin Skrtel and Sims V rudenko on the
most general of all these machine
scheduling models and there is unrelated
machine scheduling which already has
been talked about quite a lot this
morning okay so if you are unsure what
is stochastic scheduling and what is
exactly all of that don't worry
everything will be defined okay so let
me start by setting the scene looking
from the deterministic perspective and
what is known about these problems and I
really start with a simplest problem
that you that you can imagine also to
fix a little bit of the notation so we
have n jobs and these drops have weights
W and processing times P let's assume
they are integer and in my talk these
jobs are non pre-emptive so once started
they must not be interrupted okay so if
you want to sequence these jobs on a
single machine each job receives a
completion time which will be denoted CJ
and it's a very well-known result which
actually doesn't even deserve the name
to be a result but it's known as Smith's
rule the best thing to do is you
sequence the jobs in the order wait over
processing time so largest wait of a
processing time first so largest
relative importance of the job goes
first and that's a simple exchange
argument so that problem is not
interesting now suppose we want to
schedule the same jobs but now we have a
set of identical and peril machines okay
still we want to minimize the same
objective function I forgot to mention
that we want to minimize the total
weighted sum of the
completion times okay or the total sum
of the completion times wait could wait
could also be one on a set of identical
machines the problem gets a little bit
more interesting but also that case is
completely set alert essentially so it
is one of the problems that was listed
strongly np-hard in the book by Gary and
Johnson if you do Smith's rule so that
means whenever a machine falls idle you
pick the drop with remaining highest
ratio weight of a processing time and
you do that one that's known to be a 1.2
approximation and that is tight by this
paper by kappa gucci and q1 q1 and since
about 15 years we know that there exists
of PETA's so also this case is
essentially closed right now move on one
further now assume these machines are no
longer identical so the processing times
of the jobs can depend on the machine on
which it is processed so once again that
means for instance it could mean that
this read job over here is quicker on
the first machine but longer on the
second machine and that could be
completely reverse for some other jobs
right so there is no dependence
whatsoever the problem also gets more
challenging it's there does not exist an
approximation scheme so it's a px heart
that is known and until about a year ago
three half's approximation was the best
known which was described in several of
the papers in scheduling theory but
since about a year we know that you can
get below this three-halves by a very
remarkable results by Nikhil Ola and I
have it ok now this talk is going to be
about stochastic scheduling so that
means the processing times of the jobs
will become stochastic variables random
variables so let me at this point in
time already mention what the results is
going result is going to be so we show
that for stochastic unrelated machine
scheduling you can get a 3 plus Delta
over 2 approximation ok so that's a
three half's approximation if that Delta
wouldn't be there and that Delta will be
defined a little bit later but you
should think of it as a measure for the
variability of a job it is an upper
bound on the squared coefficient of
variation of the job so the higher the
variability the worse our approximation
guarantee is getting here okay so that's
the result but I first of all have to
define what a stochastic scheduling okay
now let me do that so the main
difference to all the other models is
now that when we see a job it's
something in between clairvoyant and non
clear volume so when we see a job we get
a distribution for its processing time
okay so the best way to think of it for
this talk is in terms of say survival
probabilities look at this green job
over here so it's maybe started at time
0 and that is corresponding to a
discrete distribution here which has a
processing time of 1 with probability
1/2 and if not 1 then it will be 3 or 4
each with probability 1 over 4 ok so
that would be and then this staircase
function describes the survival
probability for this job over time if it
started at time 0 so this would be a
discrete distribution but in general it
can also be a continuous or whatever
distribution I don't care ok so that's
the input that you get and that is also
what you get to see so you see you get
these input distributions now what is
the solution to such a problem the
solution is of course no longer a
schedule because I cannot I can no
longer assign a fixed starting time to a
job that depends on what has happened
before and that is all random variables
so the solution is going to be what is
known as a non anticipatory scheduling
policy and one way to think of it
suppose everything is discrete that
makes it easier to think about it one
way to think of that is it's just a huge
decision tree which for each state that
you might come across decides how to go
next so this job has ended first ok so I
then continue that way and so on and so
on so it's just a huge decision tree and
non anticipatory refers to the fact that
at any point in time I am of course
allowed to use all the information that
I have accumulated over the past
but I'm not allowed to look into the
future so if you look at this figure
here that's the same green job from
above here you realize that at this
point in time it has not been a process
in terms of one so it must be three or
four so this extra information you can
use in future decisions but you are not
allowed to look into the future of those
not and not yet finished jobs yes
there's a question no it's all non
pre-emptive so once you have started a
job you can not preempted anymore you
have to finish it until the end any
other questions at this point yes
completely different yes so here these
this large pj we're now denote the
random variable for a job if it does not
depend on the machine or it will be pIJ
if it does depend on the machine and
that can be arbitrary like in the
unrelated machine scheduling models any
other questions at this point yes yes it
could be yeah it could be arbitrary or
what do you know no no no all right okay
so one thing that you have to think
about how do you define optimality for
this setting because suppose you have an
instance and you have a scheduling
policy you have chosen one then the
outcomes of the cost of the schedule is
going to be a random variable so how do
we compare two different scheduling
policies and what I do here is the
simplest thing we just compare their
expectations so we call a policy optimal
if it achieves the minimum expected
performance among all non non
anticipatory policies all right and you
might ask I mean I wrote an infimum here
because I mean this could be an
uncountable set right thus an optimal
policy actually always exists and there
is a quite general result that shows
that under very mild circumstances yes
an optimum policy actually exists which
also attains this infimum here okay so
in particular that's true for the
setting I'm considering
here alright so that is the notion of
optimality and let me go through a
little example here so here there's a
question yes yes they have considered
stochastic scheduling exactly yeah
that's absolutely right yeah okay back
to this example we have four jobs we
have two deterministic jobs that is blue
jobs they have a processing time of one
and we have two stochastic jobs that
these green jobs over here and they can
either they disappear with large
probability four over five or they turn
out to be very long I mean this is going
to be the constructions for all the bad
examples of course with probability one
over five and notice that the expected
processing time of these green jobs will
be two okay now let me ask you suppose
you want to schedule these four jobs on
two machines which goes first blue or
green any intuitions expectation very
good answer I mean green doing green
first is a kind of gamble right I mean
you hope that they turn out to be short
and then you are getting in good shape
the answer is both is wrong it's it's
even more complicated so my claim here
is that there is a kind of delicate
trade of going on between balancing say
you want to delay that jobs which have a
large processing times because there
will be there will be blocking your
machine and expectation but you want to
also delay jobs which have a high
probability of getting very long so
that's the heavy tail jobs and for this
simple instance the only optimum policy
is really to start a green and a blue
job and then you have to continue with
green and then you do the last blow job
ok it has a certain expected completion
time here I forgot to mention that in
this example all the weights are one so
it's just a total expected completion
time of the jobs okay
proof just work it out I mean it's a
simple case distinction right I mean
anything else is worse than that
and because it's so nice I have this
picture here so I start a green and the
blue job then with high probability I
can immediately start the second green
job here right with small probability
the second green job has to wait for the
blue job and then the final job arrives
this second deterministic job with
reasonably high probability it can even
go in the first machine or it has to
wait for the blue job if the first green
job turned out to be long or it even has
to wait for the second green job on the
second machine or it will go at the very
end only when the long green job has
finished right with small probability so
that's how such a schedule is going to
look like okay and one important thing
already now I will come back to that it
seems like in this schedule there is a
lot of air which looks kind of
suboptimal but I mean this is how a
schedule looks like okay all right so
you can even Drive this example or such
examples a little bit further and I just
mentioned it very briefly you can show
or you can construct instances if you
also introduce weights where any optimal
policy has to deliberately leave a
machine idle okay so very briefly only
so we have this red job which is super
important and it's either blocking the
machine forever we have two machines
here or it just vanishes after a very
small amount of time Epsilon right
because it's so expensive you must do it
first and that means if you wait until
the time epsilon then you know if you
will have one or two machines available
for the remaining jobs I didn't specify
these jobs here but they are all
stochastic here and it could be that if
you have one machine available that you
want to do the blue jobs first and if
you have two machines available you want
to do the green jobs for green jobs
first and you can construct such
examples rather easily and then the
really only optimal thing is to leave
this machine idle for a small amount of
time to gain information in which
situation em are actually in okay so the
bottom line of all this discussion and
the example is optimum policies yeah
there is a question
I have no clue but the gap in this
example is negligible it's very small
but it's it's a constant yeah that's
right this is with weights without
weights still I don't know it's as far
as I know it's open with arbitrary
distributions okay anyway so the bottom
bottom line of this example and also the
previous one is that you know it at
least looks like intuitively optimum
policies that can be huge exponential
size may be decision trees there it's
definitely np-hard or AP x are depending
on if we work on identical or unrelated
machines because already the
deterministic case is hard and let's
constraint contained as a special case
and also there is results showing that
if you give me a policy computing the
expected value of that policy may be a
number P hard problem okay I mean a
better hardness result would be a nice
thing I will come back to that in the
conclusions so that at least you know it
seems reasonable to be okay with
approximation algorithms and the
definition of an approximation algorithm
for me is going to be we have that the
expected cost of our policy pi is not
more than alpha times the expected cost
of an optimal scheduling policy and here
is an important difference I'm not
comparing to the offline optimum here
I'm comparing to the best non
anticipatory policy which of course I
don't know okay so the adversary here is
definitely weaker than the offline
optimum there is different models which
have been considered by Angela cash
taker and others but our adversary is
non anticipatory too so we compare with
the best thing that you can do given
that the future is uncertain that's what
we do here so let me talk a little bit
about approximation algorithms for
these kind of scheduling problems so we
have been able to show in this paper
quite some time ago so that there exists
constant factor approximation algorithms
as long as you have an upper bound on
the coefficient of variation of these
random variables okay so the bound is
three again three plus deltar divided by
two so for instance if you assume
exponentially distributed processing
times the coefficient of variation is
exactly one so that would be a two
approximation okay the special case
deterministic processing times is three
halves and so on so that's a result that
holds true for Smiths rule on identical
and parallel machines okay there have
been several extensions for instance two
problems with precedence constraints or
to the setting where these stochastic
jobs actually arrive online this is not
the case for the model that I explained
so far so far everything is just given
from the outset but they also might
arrive online and you can also do
something their bottom line of this yes
that's exactly right that is total
expected completion time or total
expected to wait at the completion time
yes
it can include weights it's just linear
so that doesn't really all these results
are however four identical machines and
not four unrelated machines and they use
except for this one paper this one paper
here they all use either in the
algorithmic construction or in the lower
bound a linear programming lower bound
that we came up with in this paper here
and let me just briefly show you what
that is so the core ingredient of this
LP is what is sometimes called load
inequalities for scheduling problems and
I don't want to really pass this it's
the only thing that is maybe interesting
to see is that we have on the left hand
side here something where that involves
the expected completion times of jobs
under a certain policy right and on the
right hand side we have some function
which turns out to be super modular so
that
can actually optimize over this
polyhedron efficiently and that's an
inequality for each possible subsets of
the jobs and the interesting thing here
is that you see this red term here which
includes the variance of the jobs with a
negative sign so that means the higher
the variance of the random variables
that we put in the weaker these
inequalities get and this is exactly how
we get this coefficient of variation
into the performance bounds okay so
these inequalities actually generalize
LPS that have been used earlier in
deterministic settings and quite an
amount of papers all right so the point
is it this cannot be generalized to the
general unrelated machine setting at
least not in any meaningful meaningful
way and at least not that I'm aware of
so let us turn to unrelated machine
scheduling and now I talked about the
recent results that we obtained and then
I conclude with yet another paper that
appeared last year okay so first of all
so now really the setting is unrelated
machines arbitrary processing time
distributions on different machines so
the first observation is that it's not
too difficult to convince yourself that
it essentially is no loss of generality
if we assume discrete distributions
discrete integer value discrete
distributions okay we just do that by
shifting I mean suppose you have a
continuous variable you just shift all
the probability through the next highest
integer point and then the rest is just
standard scaling and bla bla bla so that
costs a1 plus epsilon so let's assume
that is the case that means we can
define these variables here X IJ T which
denote the probability for a given
policy to start the job J on a machine I
at a particular time T so that's going
to be a time Index formulation for the
problem and just I mean let's take this
example that I had earlier already so a
job of course starts probabilistically
at different points in time so if we
again think of this blue job which is
the last one to be scheduled the
corresponding variables
what we like this right with a certain
probability the blue job was starting at
time zero and the first machine with a
certain probability on time one on the
second machine and then here again with
a small probability at time ten on the
first machine again so that would be the
corresponding variables that correspond
to the policy that I showed earlier and
that was just greedily scheduling the
jobs in this order all right is that
clear
now let's using these variables let's
set up an LP and the most important
thing about this light is coming now so
how do i express the expected completion
time of a job in these variables okay
it's important to remember that policies
are non anticipatory so at the moment
that I start a job what will be the
processing time for this job in
expectation it will just be the expected
processing time of that job because the
decision to schedule a job must be
independent of the actual processing
time of the job and therefore I can just
Express the expected completion time
like this right if I decide to start a
job at time T that's independent of the
actual processing time so the completion
time will just be the starting time T
plus it's it's expected processing time
on that particular machine so here we
really need that policies are not
allowed to look into the future and the
rest is just kind of standard so each
job should of course be scheduled on any
one of the machines and now in order to
model the constraint that any machine
can only do one job at a time we write
down the probability for a job to be in
process at a particular time so let's
say at this time three here to be in
process at that time the job should have
been started earlier and it must still
be alive
right and this is just what I write down
here it has been started at some time
here and it should still be alive at
that time that I look at and I just add
up over all these times from zero to
time s that I'm considering
okay so that's a probability for one job
now if I sum that up over all the jobs
right I know that that cannot be more
than one because each machine can only
do one job at a time and that's already
the whole LP that's it I mean that's
it's not very difficult okay so that's
the LP and well a solution might look
like this and I show this picture here
to make clear that this LP does not
model the stochastic scheduling problem
it's really only a relaxation because in
this LP we are they are kind of solving
this Tetris game where everything will
be as much shifted to the beginning as
possible but that's not necessarily a
scheduling scheduling policy the next
slide max makes that even clearer
suppose I have just two jobs one after
each other on one machine and they have
exponentially distributed processing
times so for any time T there is
positive probability that the second job
will start at that time T right so do we
have to deal with this infinite size LP
here so that might be a technical
problem so the solution the actual
solution of the situation may adjust
scheduled the jobs one after the other
will look like this but the answer is no
exactly because the LPD
can do more things right the LP can just
for instance accumulate the the big bulk
of all these probabilities together and
put it as early as can so that would be
a feasible solution of the linear
program but in what again not correspond
to a solution of the scheduling problem
right so with this an inside it's not
too difficult to show that the LP always
has a finite optimal solution and we can
actually buy it by usual tricks and
scheduling so that we can solve it
efficiently up to arbitrary precision so
there is an FPT us to solve this LP
alright so I'm about to come to the
final algorithm so the algorithm again
is also very simple we just solve this
LP say optimally or proximately
optimally and now we just assign jobs to
machines right in the beginning
according to the probabilities that have
been proposed by the Flynn
programming solution right now that we
have probabilistically but everything
can be Duran demised assigned jobs to
machines we know a certain set of jobs
on a single machine and on a single
machine we know what the optimum thing
is to do it's just using Smith's rule
even though these processing times are
stochastic but on a single machine that
doesn't matter it's no difference okay
so that's the algorithm and that gives a
3 plus Delta over 2 approximation so
that's the results again let me give you
one two slides of the analysis we are
not analyzing this algorithm actually
the difficulty with analyzing this thing
is that the smiths rule of course does
not really connect to our LP solution so
that doesn't work so what we are going
to do is we just impose on each of the
machines a different order which
corresponds more or less exactly to the
LP solution and this is how we do that
so it's provably worse what we are doing
but it can be analyzed okay so we find
an optimum LP solution down there and
for each stop we decide according to the
LP to which machine it should go and at
which point in time right so that's for
instance this read job here then what we
introduce is an additional delay for
this job
okay this R here is going to be an
additional delay that we put on this job
which and the amount of the delay is
probabilistic it depends on the
probability and the tail probability
essentially of the job so jobs which
have a large tail have a larger
probability of being delayed even
further than this would then the LP
suggested okay then we set the tentative
start time of the job to be what the LP
suggested that is the T plus this
additional delay all right so let's do
that here is an additional delay for
this job two time units for this red job
we do that for all the jobs so these
bullets now here denote the tentative
start times of the jobs and now we just
sequence the jobs according to these
tentative start times so that that's the
right order that we want to consider
here
so in each machine we do the jobs not in
the order of Smith's rule which would be
optimal but in this different order and
in order to analyze that I just state
the key lemma so if a job J has been
assigned to machine I and has this
tentative start time s we can show that
the total expected processing that
happens before is exactly at most this s
plus 1/2 ok
this 1/2 actually comes comes from
solving ties if two jobs received the
same tentative starting time ok in doing
that I can immediately write down an
upper bound for the expected completion
time of a job right what is that well
it's the total expected processing that
happened before we have an upper bound
for that that is s plus 1/2 plus it's
expected processing time and that is of
course conditioned on the fact that the
job has been assigned there right and
the rest is just calculus I mean there
is nothing serious going on yes there is
a question yes that's absolutely right I
mean if you would do it based on the
ratio weight over expected processing
time that's that's how you define it and
that is optimal on one machine
absolutely there's even a paper where
that what meant was mentioned in the 60s
yeah okay so that's the analysis now if
you think yeah well why it didn't be oh
wait I wanted to mention one thing
namely where does this Delta creep in
again this this was an upper bound on
the variability of the job it exactly
creeps in because our tentative start
time s that had this additional term
which D was dependent on the tail
distribution of the job and this term
kind of screws up the performance bound
so this turns out to be exactly if you
work it out just an upper bound or
exactly equal to the coefficient of
variation here it's it's quite funny
that we obtain exactly the same bound
even though we use a completely
different algorithm and also a
completely
current analysis so when we first wrote
the paper we thought we had something
better than that which would have been
great because we would have beaten the
three halves as well but I mean of
course that was not true so it's exactly
the same bound that we obtained before
using different algorithms now if you
think how could this be improved there
is one obvious thing so the algorithm
that we use is stupid in the sense that
right in the beginning we assign jobs to
machines and that's it so we we do not
gain anything from adaptivity because we
do not adapt right everything has been
assigned in the beginning so what we
show is any such policy that a science
right in the beginning can have an
optimality gap which essentially is
Delta over two so it depends on the
coefficient of variation right so if you
want to get better than that you might
think okay so let's take the LP and
let's try to define an adaptive policy
that somehow depends on this LP solution
but also this doesn't work because we
can also show simple examples but I
don't have time to show them now this
time index LP also can have an
optimality gap Delta over two so with
this LP you won't get anything better
right that is even on one machine and
the idea is essentially that the LP is
allowed to slice drops and tiny parts
and do all that in parallel this is kind
of that is the idea another question
sorry yeah it's it's yeah it's it's a
nasty distribution again yes yeah that's
a very good point because I mean once
assume something more about the
distribution maybe something better can
be shown I mean that would be one of my
my questions at the end I'm about to
finish okay so let me give some final
remarks so
obviously to improve it seems that the
privity seems to be a good thing so
whenever some machine turns out to be
empty you may want to revise your
decision and do some jobs there but if
you think let's just analyze smith's
rule I mean only adaptivity is not
enough
right so the Smith rule just greedily
scheduling the job jobs according to
ratio weight over expected processing
times also can be as bad as essentially
well the coefficient of variation of the
underlying random variables okay
square root of that so the the open
problems really are can we find say a
constant factor approximation which does
not depend on the variability of the
jobs so independent of that or maybe
show that this is impossible right and
anyhow it's also open to really prove
non-trivial for this particular model at
least non-trivial hardness bounds so I
could imagine the problem is maybe
pspace heart but all the peace based
hardness proofs kind of need more
structure so this problem has has too
little structure or yeah maybe there
maybe that is possible I mean it would
be very interesting to get something
that goes beyond NP hardness for this
for this problem in this first direction
there was a very nice paper by son Jing
and Ben and Kirk stacks last year where
they showed yes you can find
approximation algorithms which do not
depend on this coefficient of variation
in their case at the expense of well an
additional factor of M for instance but
the very cute thing here is to remark
that the algorithm that they use in
order to do so does exactly this balance
between jobs with high expected
processing time and jobs with may turn
out to be very long with a reasonably
large probability so that's exactly the
algorithm that they are analyzing and I
guess I'm kind of out of time but Ben
and something here and maybe can explain
at some later point in time a little bit
more about that
I had some slide here I mean what they
what they essentially show is that if
you extrude exclude the right jobs then
the probability that our algorithm which
is excluding the right sets of jobs
blocks all machines beyond some deadline
towhere then that probability must be
smaller than the probability that some
optimal scheduling policy blocks all
jobs beyond that deadline which is
slightly scaled by by this factor alpha
here right so that's the core insight
that they and why I mean why is that
true well because the algorithm chooses
exactly the right jobs which which you
know have small expected processing time
and do not have large tails okay also a
very nice result I would say so that's
it so let me conclude with just
displaying some of the papers
31 32